[Music]
in Amsterdam I dreamt I saw my mother
again same beautiful pale blue eyes
[Music]
when I lost her I lost sight of any
landmark that might have led me
someplace happier
you're a boy are you the boy whose
mother was killed
[Music]
Ansel you know for people who haven't
read the book just kind of give us a
general sort of about what the story is
well it's a really big book so it's hard
to generalize it but I'll do my best
basically this guy's Theo his mother
dies in an explosion at the Metropolitan
Museum of Art when he's a young kid when
he's Oakes's age and while in the
explosion he is confused and he ends up
taking this masterpiece painting the
Goldfinch and from there from then on he
ends up you know his father was a
screw-up drunk who actually lives in Las
Vegas and he's with his mother in New
York but his mother's has died now and
he has nowhere to go and see it's hard
to generalize it but I he ends up
basically putting a lot into this
painting he sort of the paintings like
his mother and he holds on to it for
dear life and ends up then getting into
a lot of trouble and has kind of an epic
life with a lot of hardship and somehow
has to overcome that and that's I guess
my job once we finally get to me you
know I think it's interesting and I feel
like we are seeing some films lately
that are about a piece of art or
whatever it is a music a song a poem you
know literal painting that sort of
changes your life and changes who you
are moving forward and I'd love to ask
each of you if there is a piece of art
be it a poem a music a song a movie that
you experienced and it sort of changed
you moving forward anok's I'll start
here that's it's it's difficult
sometimes I mean I'm sure it's for some
people that's really clear and for some
people it's not so much um there's not
necessarily something
specific but I love Turner paintings and
they are great and whenever you go to
any Museum and there's a Turner painting
I feel like I'm just immediately drawn
to that I just feel like it holds a lot
of raw emotion and it changes me every
time I see any painting so it's um it's
really great to see that cool hmm I'm so
struggling next there's many things that
you know I hold so many songs I wouldn't
know where to begin
yeah um something that changed me I
guess when I was about 11 I watched
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid for
the first time and that changed
everything for me in my mind and it blew
my socks off and not really then geared
me into the the old acting weird my sort
of similar when I was four I saw a
Broadway production of Oklahoma yeah and
I think Hugh Jackman is in it I was four
so I wouldn't know who was who
but I loved the guy will who did the
lasso tricks and he's saying I got the
Kansas City on a Friday but Saturday I
learned a thing or two didn't have an ID
of what the modern where I was coming to
a saying the song and I remember being
like I was from then I was totally in
the show and I loved Oklahoma and I got
the soundtrack I learned every song and
think and then I that's what I wanted to
do you think they offered you now the
last guy damn right yeah I don't
remember his name I things will or
something but yeah I saw that and I
would that was it
yeah mine I mean well first time I heard
the Beatles obviously a huge moment I
mean there's I you know because we're
still growing we have stuff that happens
all the time I was a teenager I don't
you know I was talking about harmony
Corrine earlier mmm and he didn't wait
and direct it but uh I saw kids for the
first time like a year ago
like just changed everything for me I
was like you can make movies like this
like you can I just I don't know if
there's something about so raw and a 400
blows to UM to movies that I think are
not being made anymore one because of
legal reasons and two because you just
can't replicate it um my jaw with cream
yeah oh no I have a list of directors
that I do you let anything with that's
why you see the beach bum yeah I just
saw it's great great feel-good movie
with Matthew McConaughey where he lays a
STONER that's like everything you want
to be back to the movie is if there's
one thing that sort of you want
audiences to know about this film before
they watch it you know what would that
one thing be I mean dude that's yeah
it's right I mean it's also one of those
it's it's not a thing where you know you
you could definitely do you know we were
just talking about like how you sit at a
movie it's one of those movies you can't
really you know it's a it's there's a
lot of different things going on so it's
one of those things you can't really
wait back you know you're not it's it's
a very speak for yourself
well it's a very like crazy experience I
mean it's like it's it's watching the
movie as a very there's there's so many
things that go through the character
yeah I mean yeah so true yeah I mean
there's something I think audiences have
to have to expect to just be engulfed in
what this character is feeling mmm
there's a lot of depths in this you know
because of the book so big you know and
then if there's a lot to be told you
know one high on screen for a modern
audience you know everyone wants really
quick movies now you know we don't make
any three-hour movies or anything like
that this movies kind of it's not the
three hour movie but it is it honors the
old fashioned kind of go into a cinema
and watching a good epic movie you know
some sort where you can fall into and
disappear and you know John and the
producers and the team have really kind
of honored that and then with respect
then on at the book you know because
they haven't they tried to keep as much
as possible but then translates now on
the screen so
for people that don't know the book
they'll go and have a really in-depth
experience hopefully and the people that
do know the book hopefully they'll feel
like the film doesn't let the book death
yeah and even with that and with it
being a long longer movie that respects
that it has a quality that keeps you
completely like fence that engulfed in
it yeah and I think that's really good
but also I think if there's something
that I want people to like really know
before they they jump into the
experience um would just be too to let
yourself let yourself go and let
everybody in the movie affect you
because everybody in the in the movie
has their own different things that
they're going through and I think
everybody can relate to that right yeah
try to be vulnerable when you see this
movie yeah that's good place to be
yeah as we wrap up you know CinemaCon is
very much about sort of geeking out
about upcoming sort of films is there
anything that's upcoming that you guys
personally beaking out about I was
hoping Joaquin Phoenix was gonna be here
me too do not know if he is but I mean I
don't know the joke is gonna be crazy
something good to see I think what
stories Tom Hardy is doing everything
man he's Tory he's doing stuff great
answer thank you
it's hard is how hard you have the West
Side Story are you doing that which is
kind of speaks to that musical thing
yeah exactly exactly it's living lasa
living living the dream and I but I got
to bring justice to that mmm and there's
a whole amazing group of people working
on it I'm lucky to be part of the team
and hopefully I can do my best work
you